>> Sean: JOHN IS CAUTIOUS.
IT'S NOT ABOUT WHO IS RIGHT
BUT WHAT IS RIGHT.
FOR THIS TO BE IGNORED,
THERE IS NO EXCUSE FOR IT.
THANK YOU ALL.
ANOTHER BIG STORY WE ARE
FOLLOWING TONIGHT, LIBERALS,
DEMOCRATS, THEY CONTINUE TO
MOBILIZE AGAINST PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S PICK FOR THE CIA
DIRECTOR.
HER NAME IS GINA HASPEL.
IF CONFIRMED BY THE SENATE,
SHE WOULD BECOME THE FIRST
WOMAN TO LEAD THE CIA, TO
LEAD THAT EGG A CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRAT DIANNE FEINSTEIN,
SHE IS NOW CALLING FOR THE
PUBLIC RELEASE OF DOCUMENTS
ON HASPEL'S INVOLVEMENT IN
ENHANCED INTERROGATION AND
DETENTION OF RADICAL
ISLAMMIST TERRORISTS
FOLLOWING THE ATTACKS AND
THE MURDER OF 3,000
AMERICANS ON 9/11.
NOW, FEINSTEIN IS ONLY THE
LATEST LIBERAL LAWMAKER TO
QUESTION WHETHER HASPEL WAS
TOO TOUGH ON JIHADIS.
AND BY THE WAY, IT'S NOT
JUST LAWMAKERS ATTACKING
HASPEL.
JOINING US WITH REACTION IS
THE HOST OF WAR STORIES
OLIVER NORTH.
WITHOUT ENHANCED
INTERROGATION THERE IS NO
BIN LADEN, TRUE OR FALSE
MR. OLLIE NORTH.
>> THE FOLKS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY RESIDENT DOWN IN
GITMO WOULDN'T BE THERE FOR
WHAT GINA HASPEL AND WHAT
HER BRAVE COLLEAGUES DID.
GINA HASPEL IS THE PERSON
NEEDED TO HEAD THE CIA IN
THIS NEW WORLD DISORDER.
WITHOUT GOING THROUGH ALL
THE LITANY THAT YOU WENT
THROUGH AT THE VERY
BEGINNING OF THIS BROADCAST,
THIS WOMAN SPENT 30 YEARS AS
AN OPERATIONS OFFICER WITH
NUMEROUS FOREIGN POSTINGS.
SHE IS, QUITE FRANKLY,
ADMIRED BY MOST OF HER
COLLEAGUES.
I HAVE NOT TALKED TO ANYBODY
AT THE HEADQUARTERS
CURRENTLY OR WHO WAS THERE
WHO KNOW HER WHO DON'T THINK
THE WORLD OF HER.
DIANNE FEINSTEIN OUGHT TO
RETIRE NOW.
LOOK, SHE IS GRAND STANDING
ABOUT WATERBOARDING WHEN IT
WAS DEEMED TO BE LEGAL BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE,
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL, AND
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES U IN OTHER WORDS, SHE
DID HER DUTY.
IT WAS ONLY AFTERWARDS THAT
THEY DECIDED IT REALLY
WASN'T LAWFUL.
I THINK I KNOW A LITTLE BIT
WHAT IT IS LIKE WHAT HAPPENS
TO PEOPLE WHO DO THEIR DUTY
AND CONGRESS DISAGREES.
>> Sean: COLONEL, HAVE YOU
BEEN WATERBOARDED IN YOUR
LIFE IN YOUR CAREER IN THE
MILITARY AS A MARINE THAT
SERVES HIS COUNTRY AND HAVE
A PURPLE HEART OR TWO, I
THINK TWO?
>> LOOK, I WAS A SURVIVAL
INVASION, RESISTANCE AND
ESCAPE.
I USED TO TEACH IT.
I WAS WATERBOARDED WHEN I
WENT THROUGH THE COURSE.
I WATERBOARDED AT LEAST 150
PEOPLE.
SOME OF WHOM I'M SURE WERE
WONDERING WHAT THE HECK IS
GOING ON BECAUSE IT WAS ALL
LEGAL BEFORE.
WE USED TO DO IT TO PEOPLE.
YOU NEED TO BE PREPARED FOR
THIS KIND OF THING.
I GUESS THAT HAS ALL STOPPED
AS WELL NOW.
LOOK, ALL THAT ENDED FOR ME.
I HOPE IT ENDS WELL FOR THE
NEW DCI GINA HASPEL.
THE PRESIDENT AND OUR
COUNTRY NEEDS HER RIGHT
THERE AND I DON'T NEED TO
DRAG HER THROUGH TORTURE.
>> Sean: WHAT OTHER WAY,
HAVE YOU SOMEBODY LIKE KSM.
KHALID SHEIKH MOHAMMED, THE
MASTER MIND OF 9/11, THE
WORST ATTACK IN AMERICAN
HISTORY ON OUR SOIL KILLING
3,000 AMERICANS.
OBVIOUSLY DECLARING WAR ON
THIS COUNTRY.
IS THERE A NICE WAY TO
ABSTRACT INFORMATION.
BUILD THE SOCCER FIELDS AND
TAKE CARE OF THE DIETARY
CONCERNS AND ORDER PERSONAL
CHEFS FOR THOSE ON THE
BATTLEFIELD TRYING TO KILL
AMERICANS, IS THAT GOING TO
WORK?
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW I HAVE
NOT BEEN INVOLVED IN
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
I HAVE QUESTIONED PEOPLE IN
THE FIELD WHEN THEY HAVE
BEEN CAPTURED.
I HAVE PUT SOME OF THAT UP
ON YOUR SHOW FROM OVERSEAS.
ALL YOU HAD TO DO TO SOME OF
THESE GUYS WAS TO TELL THEM
THROUGH THE INTERPRETER,
THIS IS A HIGH VALUED
TARGET.
JUST BEEN GRABBED BY A
SPECIAL OPERATIONS TEAM.
AND I PUT THIS ON AIR.
WE COULDN'T SHOW THE GUY'S
FACE, OF COURSE.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, THERE
IS A REPORT TONIGHT THAT I
HAVEN'T CONFIRMED IT THAT
THIS WOMAN DID NOT OVERSEE
THE WATERBOARDING OF ABU IS
A BADE DA, IF YOU
ISBADE DA, IF YOU
ISAADE DA, IF YOU
ISA ZE DA, IF YOU
ISA ZUBDA, IF YOU
ISA ZUBAY, IF YOU
ISA ZUBAYDAIF YOU
ISA ZUBAYDAHF YOU
ISA ZUBAYDAH IYOU
ISA ZUBAYDAH IFOU
ISA ZUBAYDAH IF YOU REMEMBER.
>> I PUT GUYS ON AIR FROM
OVERSEAS WHO HAD JUST BEEN
CAPTURED.
OKAY.
ALL YOU HAD TO DO TO SOME OF
THOSE GUYS IS SAY SHIP THEM
TO GITMO IN THE LOCAL
LANGUAGE.
WHETHER IT WAS FARSI OR
ARABIC AND THEY WOULD PUKE
RIGHT THERE ON THE SPOT.
>> Sean: APPRECIATE YOU.